[Music]
work to pay the bills steady so I can
get three mils heavy it weighs on me
swear together did kill me a little more
every day I'm punching in I'm punching
out it feels a bit like to kick not okay
eat some fresh and some sleep
need some coffee needs a white when can
I get my Pig sweet believe have some
type of this game involves around me
never we're gonna cut it anyway okay
well it's a special set but you just in
your marriage you wait baby I can't get
your breath
get your bread they told me gets my
future hat success you gotta get
yourself a thousand to get my fish so is
it too much to ask for what you used to
chip see I've been working just a little
bit dining/living to work too many
things I wanna do
[Music]
so much always running